ein XXL Politiker Horst Seehofer
50 Jahre CSU 28 Jahre Bundestag zehn
Jahre bayerischer Ministerpräsident nun
tritt er ab der politische Riese Bild
Blick zurück Seehofer ist 20 Jahre alt
als seine politische Laufbahn beginnt
1969 wird er Mitglied der Jungen Union
1971 tritt er dann in die CSU ein Anfang
der 80er Jahre wird Seehofer
Bundestagsabgeordneter 89 folgt dann das
erste große Amt da ist er 40 Jahre alt
die Berufung zum Staatssekretär nur drei
Jahre später wird er 1992
Bundesgesundheitsminister unter Kanzler
Kohl bis zum Regierungswechsel 1998
erhält er dieses Amt was viele nicht
wissen im Jahr 2002 erkrankt Seehofer
schwer an einer Herzmuskelentzündung die
ihn zwar nicht sein Amt aber fast das
Leben gekostet hätte nach dem
Krankenhausaufenthalt sagt er später
dass er sich wegen der hohen
Arbeitsbelastung nicht behandeln lassen
habe
Seehofer kommt zurück in der großen
Koalition ist der ab 2005 wieder
Bundesminister diesmal für Ernährung und
Landwirtschaft dann folgen zehn Jahre
als Ministerpräsident das Freistaates
Bayern und gleichzeitig ist er
CSU-Vorsitzender fast unbemerkt 2012 ist
er für vier Wochen sogar Bundespräsident
als Christian Wulff zurücktritt führt er
die Geschäfte sein letztes großes Amt
und es Innenminister in Merkels vierten
Kabinett bis zu dieser Woche ist
Seehofer Deutschlands dienstältester
Minister und hat gestern am 26 Oktober
2021 seine Entlassungsurkunde erhalten
Politik ist jeden Tag ein Spießrutenlauf
sagt Horst Seehofer wie er das 50 Jahre
durchgehalten hat und was er nun ohne
diesen Spießrutenlauf macht darüber
spricht er jetzt bei Bild live
ja herzlich willkommen was geht durch
den Kopf wenn sie die Bilder sehen
ein Kompliment für Bild das stimmt alles
das ist sehr sehr gut welcher Horst
Seehofer den wir da gesehen haben war
der beste für Deutschland
ach gut man kann da kein Amt besonders
herausheben es war jedes Amt sehr
anspruchsvoll vom Gesundheitsminister
über Landwirtschaftsminister ich kann
mich noch an meine Rede im Bundestag
erinnern und meine erste Rede als
Landwirtschaftsminister war ja
ungebündlich für einen
städtischen Politiker da kam der Ruf
weißt du eigentlich wie eine Kuh von
hinten aussieht das hatte eine ganz
stillen Bundestag natürlich zu einem
großen Gelächter geführt und es war dann
auch sehr anspruchsvoll und
Ministerpräsident war Mitte schönste
Strauß sagt er immer nach dem Papst das
schönste Amt auf der Welt weil man sehr
viel der Bevölkerung begegnet also ich
will jetzt da keine Wertungen vornehmen
wenn Sie sich noch an ihren allerersten
Job erinnern
vor der Politik der Einstieg ins
Berufsleben ja ja ich war dienstanfänger
die werden Angebote in der
Kommunalverwaltung in Ingolstadt
Besoldungsgruppe A1 ja das ist die
niedrigste Personen wie viel D-Mark das
war ich habe jetzt erst einmal begonnen
aufzuräumen zu Hause das waren 150
D-Mark
und wissen es noch was ich davon gekauft
habe ja ich habe dann einen kleinen
Kredit aufgenommen um einen VW Käfer zu
kaufen und habe den dann abgestattet
jetzt sind sie seit gestern nur noch
geschäftsführend im Amt das bedeutet sie
dürfen keine grundlegenden
Entscheidungen mehr treffen was machen
Sie denn ganzen Tag
ja schauen Sie ich bin an der Spitze des
Innenministeriums dazu gehören 80.000
Beschäftigte 20 nachgeordnete Behörden
wichtige Behörden wie Verfassungsschutz
Bundespolizei und sie glauben nicht sein
solche Apparat ist ständig in Bewegung
aber keine grundlegenden Entscheidungen
mehr bedeutet ja in so wichtigen Fragen
wie Grenzkontrollen Migrationspolitik
tritt jetzt so eine Phase ohne große
Handlung ein wie sehr schränkt das die
Kraft des Innenministeriums ein ja sehr
stark darum hoffe ich ja dass die
Verhandler jetzt bei der Ampelkoalition
in der Tat noch im Dezember den Kanzler
wählen denn es stehen aber trotzdem dann
zwei Monate in denen im Grunde
optimistisch ich rechne das
pessimistisch ja wie ist der Kanzler
gewählt ist vielleicht fünf Wochen aber
wichtig wäre dass die neue Regierung
bald zustande kommt denn gerade in
meinem Bereich von der inneren
Sicherheit bis zur Migration stehen sehr
sehr große Aufgaben an wir haben nicht
nur Klima sondern wir haben große große
nationale und internationale Probleme zu
lösen wir hatten vor zwei Tagen zum
ersten Mal seit vielen Jahren am Tag ein
über 1.000 Zuwanderer wenn Sie das mal
auf den Monat hochrechnen dann wissen
sie dass da dringender Handlungsbedarf
eigentlich mal aufs Jahr hoch sind
300.000 ich sag ich will
dabei bleiben ja wie es jetzt ist wir
müssen Sie kennenlernen Minister der
sozusagen Abschiedstournee macht nicht
weil das nicht kann sondern weil er
nicht mehr darf das macht mir irgendwie
ein bisschen Sorge das wirkt wie so ein
politischer Mehltau in einer Wahnsinn
wichtigen Phase ja wenn sich das
fortsetzen sollte die Zahl die ich
gerade genannt habe dann müsste man mit
denjenigen die künftig regieren mal
Kontakt aufnehmen was wir noch tun
können damit die Zahl nicht explodieren
könnte für Sie persönlich aber auch
bedeuten dass der viel zitierte
Kontrollverlust den es mal gab an den
Grenzen den sie wo sie in dem Stande
waren den sozusagen aus dem Spiel zu
nehmen die Dinge zu ordnen am Ende ihrer
Amtszeit sozusagen wieder da ist
ja wir haben jetzt keinen
Kontrollverlust wir hatten
einschließlich 1000 Leute am Tag kommen
ist kein Kontrollraum
wir hatten bis Ende September 80.000 das
ist in Deutschland
das ist ungefähr die Größenordnung die
wir immer hatten in den letzten 30
Jahren seit der deutschen Einheit
manchmal liegt es drüber manchmal
drunter und in manchen Jahren wie zwei
15 weit darüber ich sage Ihnen jetzt
eine aktuelle habe ich Ihnen eine
aktuelle Zahl gesagt die zusammen kommt
aus allen Himmelsrichtungen über die
Kanarischen Inseln über die Balkanroute
das hat sich jetzt entwickelt das war
zum Beispiel in der Wahlkampfzeit
überhaupt nicht absehbar es hat sich
jetzt entwickelt aber die Menschen waren
ja schon unterwegs also das heißt sie
sind ja nicht von über Nacht plötzlich
in Polen ja unterwegs
kluge Aufklärung dass man weiß was dass
man weiß was auf einen zukommt ja aber
wissen Sie diejenigen die da Geschäfte
machen es sind ja meistens geschleustte
Personen
die
sind auch sehr raffiniert aber wenn ich
jetzt noch mal der zusammenfasse wir
haben uns ja mal geeinigt glaube ich auf
200.000 Menschen im Jahr maximal das
Wort Obergrenze war dann irgendwie
aber 200.000 ist sozusagen die
Obergrenze weil es verträglich ist für
die Integration ist Fähigkeit genau wenn
es aber so weitergeht wie es jetzt ist
uns mindestens 300.000 das sprengt also
diese Obergrenze das ist jetzt ihre
Hochrechnung
top sage ich ja wenn wenn wir absehen
jetzt in den nächsten Tagen und Wochen
Hoppler das ist eine Dauer Zuwanderung
dann müsste ich auch als
geschäftsführender Minister noch mal mit
den Fraktionen des Deutschen Bundestages
Kontakt aufnehmen was wir noch jetzt
machen können und müssen was raten Sie
simpel in dieser Frage was ist ihr
konkreter Vorschlag was muss der nächste
Innenminister der ja nicht nur nicht
Horst Seehofer sein kann sondern auch
kein Politiker der Union mehr sein kann
nach Lage der Dinge was muss der nächste
Innenminister der Innenminister der
Ampel in dieser Frage sofort machen und
dann richtig machen ja die Lösung des
migrationsproblems wird nur gelingen
über die Europäische Union über eine
europäische Lösung mit den drei Ansätzen
die wir verfolgt haben aber leider in
der EU bisher nicht durchsetzen konnten
in den Ländern zu helfen woher die
Flüchtlinge kommen damit sie keinen
Grund haben zu flüchten zweitens an der
Außengrenze der Europäischen Union zu
prüfen wer hat überhaupt ein Recht ein
anderer Asyl zu bestellen diejenigen die
kennen kein Recht haben sofort wieder
zurück und die anderen mit einem
rechtsstaatlichen Verfahren
durchzuführen und dann in Europa zu
verteilen das wäre die beste Lösung wenn
da ist aber die Europäische Union bisher
einfach nicht aktiv genug es wäre das
wäre mein Punkt wenn man eine gute
Lösung hat wo man einen anderen starken
Partner braucht aber der macht nicht mit
dann brauchen wir wahrscheinlich eine
andere Lösung so ja dann bleibt wie
jetzt in Polen mit Belarus dass die
Polen die an der Außengrenze Europas
liegen ihrerseits eine starke
Grenzsicherung machen ich sage auch
heute noch mal was der Ministerpräsident
Kretschmer von Sachsen kürzlich gesagt
hat wir ich unterstütze die Polen bei
der Sicherung ihrer Grenzen auch mit
Befestigungsanlagen weil sie mit dieser
langen Grenze sonst nicht fertig werden
wenn das und Sanktionen gegenüber
Belarus Sanktionen gegenüber
Fluggesellschaften die die Menschen nach
Minz gepflegt wenn das auch alles nichts
nutzt was es sinnvollste wäre wenn die
EU nicht tätig wird dann dann müssen wir
auch die
polnische Grenze in den Blick nehmen das
war ja mal eine Diskussion die ist 218
schon geführt habe aber das ist die
ultima ratio jetzt ist es aber eher so
dass möglicherweise ein grüner
Innenminister ins Amt kommt die Grünen
stehen in vielen Punkten ungefähr für
das Gegenteil von dem was sie in der
Politik vertreten haben glauben sie dass
ein grüner Innenminister das so umsetzen
wird die Politik der Vernunft da geht es
ja eher um Einwanderung viele Menschen
sollen kommen keiner soll irgendwie an
einer Grenze abgewiesen werden das alles
höher ist und es macht mir Sorge wenn
ich darüber nachdenke dass es zu Politik
wird was macht es mit ihnen es geht
immerhin auch um ihr politisches
Ergebnis um ihr politisches ja
Lebenswerk ja gut wir sind wohl in der
Opposition und wir müssen dann als
Opposition eben unsere Konzepte
dagegenstellen das ist ganz ganz wichtig
da die Bundestagsfraktion von CDU und
sie so eine ganz wichtige Funktion
aber ich prophezeihe Ihnen dass die
Grünen sich auch der Realität stellen
müssen und werden denn kein Land auf
dieser Erde kann unbegrenzt Zuwanderer
auf glauben sie dass ein grüner
Innenminister Habeck
Grenzkontrollen zu Polen eine Mauer an
den polnischen Grenzen dass das die
Politik ist die im grüner wirklich
vertritt ja dann muss eben die
politische Auseinandersetzung darüber
stattfinden den Vorschlag den er bisher
macht der ist ja putzig würde ich mal
sagen wenn er sagt wir sollen die
Flüchtlinge die aus Belarus kommen
einfach in Europa verteilen das wäre die
große Genugtuung für Lukaschenko denn
wenn er weiß alle die er über die Grenze
bringt über die Schleusung und über die
staatliche Unterstützung ist eine
staatliche Schleusung die da stattfindet
alle die über die Grenze bringt wird die
EU in Europa verteilen ist es doch ganz
logisch dass er noch mehr über die
Grenze befördern wird um die Stabilität
in Europa zu gefährden das ist kein
Vorschlag der praktikable ist aber ich
sage ihnen voraus noch mal zum zweiten
Mal die Grünen werden sich dieser
Realität stellen müssen und sie werden
ihr nicht ausweichen können weil sie
sonst ja in der Bevölkerung
ja sehr stark an Vertrauen verlieren
werden die Bevölkerung will Ordnung
eine gesteuerte Zuwanderung die wir
vertragen in der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland im Hinblick auf die
Arbeitsplätze auf die Wohnungen auf die
Integration und sie will auch Humanität
ich habe zum Beispiel die jetzt noch
geschäftsführende Regierung viele
Zeichen der Humanität gesetzt nach dem
Brand auf Griechenland haben wir 3000
Kinder aufgenommen als Beispiel und
Familien also wenn Sie die Zuwanderung
steuern können Sie auch starke Signale
der Humanität setzen glauben Sie dass
die spielen so wie sie sie jetzt
wahrnehmen für diesen Schritt sich den
Gegebenheiten zu stellen genug
Vaterlandsliebe aufbringen
Vaterlandsliebe ist ja das was man in
der Politik braucht um ein Amt für die
eigenen Leute sozusagen ausüben zu
können oder irre ich mich
ja bis jetzt würde ich das noch nicht
als gegeben ansehen bei den Grünen ein
gesunder Patriotismus das hat nichts mit
Nationalismus zu tun ein gesunder
Patriotismus eine Liebe zu den Menschen
die in unserem Land leben ob sie jetzt
zugezogen sind integriert sind ob sie
hier geboren sind gehört zwingend zu
einer erfolgreichen Politik dazu wenn
Sie eine Politik die sie nicht mit dem
Herzen machen die wird nicht gelingen
und deshalb werden die Grünen der
Vernunft und der Realität nicht
ausweichen können da bin ich ziemlich
sicher
ich würde sie ihnen vorschlagen auch
wenn ich jetzt
loslasse von der Politik dass sie mich
irgendwann mir mal nach einem gewissen
Zeitablauf einladen dann können wir
diese Frage noch mal bilanzieren
außerdem
kenne ich den möglichen künftigen
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz sehr gut wir
haben zusammengearbeitet wir noch
Regierender Bürgermeister war ich
Ministerpräsident wir haben der
Bundesregierung manchen Euro aus der
Jacke gezogen gemeinsam und jetzt auch
als Finanzminister und
ich glaube und vertraue da auch auf den
Olaf Scholz wenn er denn zum Kanzler
gewählt wird dass er hier der Vernunft
zum Durchbruch verhilft
ist Robert habe ein guter Innenminister
ich weiß nicht ob er sich dafür
interessiert es Antwort genug ich habe
ich habe ihn erlebt vor vier Jahren 2017
in den jamaika-verhandlungen die wir
geführt haben und
genauso wie die Frau baerbock habe ich
sie als beide als sehr sehr sachkundige
Verhandler erlebt es ist ja nicht an den
Grünen gescheiter 2017 sondern an der
FDP ich erinnere mich dunkel wir blicken
einmal auf die Union und haben ein
kleines Geschenk für Sie mitgebracht
nämlich eine ganz besondere Tasse eine
schwarze Tasse das ist beim Politiker
immerhin noch besser als schwarze Kassen
schwarze Tasse da ist sie die ist
deshalb ganz besonders weil da drauf
steht alles wird gut haben sie die schon
mal gesehen kennen Sie die nein okay und
jetzt nicht dass jemand sagt wir werden
um geistlich gibt es einen Schluck
Kaffee und dann ist aber Kaffee es ist
es ist absolute das ist absolut Kaffee
und jetzt sehen sie mal mit uns zusammen
was mit der Tasse passiert die ändert
jetzt nämlich ihren Verlauf und da kommt
raus alles wird gut
Bundestagswahl 2021 der 26 September das
macht diese Tasse das waren Wahlkampf ja
wie soll man sagen
Artikel der CSU eine Idee von Markus
Söder der auf die Idee gekommen ist dass
alles gut wird jetzt ist da ja gefällt
ihm das
also schwarz geht weg wird weiß es mir
gefällt alles was originell ist was zum
ersten Mal am 26 September sozusagen gar
nichts gut geworden sondern eher
schlecht und wenn man in die Analyse
geht hört man natürlich Kanzlerkandidat
hat die Hauptverantwortung wie viel
Verantwortung liegt denn bei der CSU und
beim CSU-Chef
also jetzt muss ich aus ihrer Sicht mit
einer Floskel Antworten jetzt werde ich
aber nicht zulassen sie können es
versuchen
so wie man Wahlen gemeinsam gewinnt
verliert man sie auch gemeinsam ich
natürlich hat ein Spitzenkandidat wie
Armin Laschet immer eine
Hauptverantwortung aber wir haben
gemeinsam CDU und CSU
einen verkosten Wahlkampf geführt das
kann man nicht bestreiten wenn wir
gemeinsam und ja auch gut den Wahlkampf
geführt hätten hätten wir nach meiner
festen Überzeugung die stärkste Fraktion
werden können der Abstand war ja gerade
mal eineinhalb Prozent Pünktchen das
hätten wir geholt und das dies durch
Uneinigkeit und ja kein kein optimales
Programm ja und ein richtiges Team der
beiden immer aus dem Süden Söder gegen
Laschet Laschet gegen Söder
komischerweise weniger es war eher immer
so dagegen ich habe die Uneinigkeit ja
beschrieben aber sie werden mich jetzt
nicht in die Lage drängen dass ich jetzt
persönlich diesen oder jenen an den
Pranger Stelle es ist eine gemeinsame
Niederlage da ist die CDU genauso
beteiligt wie die CSU und wir müssen
vernünftig daraus die Konsequenzen
ziehen sonst wird es nicht gut aber das
nächste Mal nicht das heißt aber der
Gedanke dass mit Markus Söder an der
Spitze die Union den Kanzler stellen
würde ist schon einer der ihnen nah ist
ja gut wir haben ja zweimal in der
Geschichte der Republik den
Kanzlerkandidaten gestellt wenn wir die
Wahlergebnisse jetzt wieder erreichen
würden die diese beiden
Kanzlerkandidaten der CSU erreicht haben
dann werden wir wahrscheinlich die
glücklichste und beste Parteien ganz
Europa also was Strauß und stäuber
erreicht haben Stolper 2002 Strauß 1980
ist seitdem nicht mehr erreicht worden
und jedenfalls aus der Sicht der CSU und
deshalb war das nie verkehrt aber
natürlich hat ein CSU-Mann immer im
Herzen den geheimen Wunsch dass wir auch
mal den Kanzler stellen den Wunsch würde
ich auch nie aufgeben also mit Markus
Söder hätte hätte es klappen können der
Satz das fällt ihnen schwer
ich teile ihn auch nicht ich sage
hättest auch nicht geklappt heißt es
wissen Sie wenn Sie Kanzlerkandidat sind
dann werden sie genauso im blättert und
auf der ja durchleuchtet wie das bei
Frau bärbock geschehen ist wie es bei
armen Laschet darum kann man das jetzt
überhaupt nicht zum Maßstab machen weil
wir nicht wissen was alles geschehen
wäre
und deshalb halte ich die These ja wenn
Markus Söder Kanzlerkandidat gewesen
wäre dann wäre alles besser gelaufen für
nicht nachvollziehbar
ich sage Ihnen wir hätten auch mit Armin
Laschet bei einem geschlossenen
Wahlkampf die stärkste Fraktion werden
können wir hätten nicht mehr die alten
Wahlergebnisse erreicht das ist aber
glaube ich nach 16 Jahren Regierung
nicht so ganz überraschend da wollen
viele Leute auch einen Wechsel aber wir
hätten stärkste Fraktion werden können
aber das ist jetzt Schnee von gestern
die Leute im Land sind immer noch von
von Corona sozusagen bewegt wie gehen
wir damit um jetzt jetzt geht es ja in
die Richtung die Ampel will die
sogenannte epidemische Lage nicht Jens
Spahn will sie auch nicht mehr ist das
richtig ja diese auch wieder jedenfalls
eigenartig ist eigenartige Diskussion
die wir uns immer wieder leisten
entscheiden ist sind doch nicht die
Begriffe und irgendwelche
Grundlagen dahinter sondern entscheidend
ist wir haben mit einem potenziell
tödlichen Virus zu tun
mit einem sehr gefährlichen und
ansteckenden und auch mutierenden Virus
und da ist doch viel wichtiger was
müssen wir tun damit wir uns davor
schützen und das was ich jetzt heute in
den Nachrichten gehört habe mit der
Maske mit dem Abstand mit der 3g-regel
mit der Hyäne die jetzt gar nicht mehr
so diskutiert wird Handy sich zu waschen
und zu desinfizieren das ist doch das
entscheidende dass wir die Leute
überzeugen es macht Sinn eine Maske zu
tragen es macht nach wie vor Sinn ein
Abstand zu halten es macht nach wie vor
Sinn sich impfen zu lassen die
Hauptwaffe ist ja die Impfung auch wenn
es impft Durchbrüche gibt aber die impft
Durchbrüche verlaufen in aller Regel
milder also ich kann nur alle auffordern
einschließlich Joscha Kimmich
überlegen Sie sich noch mal und lassen
sie sich impfen sie sind eine
Persönlichkeit mit Vorbild Charakter und
wenn sie sich impfen lassen werden auch
andere Menschen sagen dann mache ich es
auch aber ich würde niemand an den
Pranger stellen wenn er sich aus
persönlich überzeugt nicht impfen lässt
und
gelesen ich bin beides übrigens ich war
auch infiziert bin habe es Gott sei Dank
überstanden oder getestet neben den
anderen Sicherheitsregeln die brauchen
wir ob jetzt dahinter eine pandemische
Lage definiert wird oder nicht
verstanden jetzt haben wir heute 23.000
Neuinfektionen das ist schon gigantisch
jetzt bleiben wir noch einmal ganz kurz
für eine schnelle Schlussrunde bei einer
Frau die ganz wichtig in ihrem Leben ist
nämlich Angela Merkel wenn ich mir ihre
Beziehung sozusagen angucke würde ich
sagen Hassliebe trifft das Nein oder
pack schlägt sich Pack verträgt sich
triffst auch nicht sondern
freundschaftlich Freundschaften bleiben
Sie mit Ihren Kontakt ich habe mich
gestern noch mal abschließend mit dir
unterhalten unter vier das haben wir in
jeder Sitzungswoche halbe Stunde getan
wir haben auch nochmal im
Schnelldurchgang unsere Jahre gemeinsam
im Jahre sind der 30
Revue passieren lassen in diesen 30
Jahren hatten wir zwei drei Diskussionen
und zwar nicht indem wir uns gegenseitig
abgesetzt haben sondern bei den
Flüchtlingen was ist sinnvoll an
Zuwanderung bei der Kopfpauschale über
wie soll die Krankenversicherung
finanziert werden nach persönlicher
Leistungsfähigkeit oder jederzeit den
gleichen Beitrag und dann noch mal 2018
mit dieser Grenzkontrolle gegenüber
Österreich aber das ist immer so geführt
worden dass wir nach dieser Diskussion
ohne dass wir uns verstellen mussten
ganz vernünftig und professionell
zusammengearbeitet haben und vielleicht
ist der beste belegherrstronz das
nachdem ich Abschied genommen hatte oder
der sich abgezeichnet hat in München als
Ministerpräsident und Parteivorsitzender
sie mich gefragt hat kann ich mit der
rechnen
so das diese Frage stellt ja in den
Mensch der froh ist wenn er eine zieht
und ich hatte das gleiche empfinden ich
war 68 Jahre da könnte man auch sagen es
reicht's aber diese Frage hat mich dann
doch noch mal zum Nachdenken gebracht
ich wusste was ich mir auflade das ist
bisher der schwierigste Job den ich
gemacht habe und
das zeigt unser Verhältnis wir haben in
diesen vier Jahren
weitestgehend unfallfrei
zusammengearbeitet und wir haben
vereinbart dass wir die Kontakte nicht
abbrechen lassen sondern weiter in
Kontakt bleiben ich habe noch
dreieinhalb ganz kurze Fragen aber
wirklich bzw die Fragen sind kurz die
Antworten müssen auch kurz sein was
nehmen sie aus dem Ministerium wenn die
Kisten gepackt sind mit nach Hause und
stellen sich in die Vitrine
alle persönlichen Dinge zum Beispiel die
Entlassungsurkunde von gestern
können sie eigentlich noch selber
Autofahren ja ich werde nicht weil ich
sie nicht zutrauen würde sondern so
langer Zeit mit Chauffeur ja wenn ich
nicht meinen offiziellen Chauffeur hat
habe ist das bisher jetzt immer in
privaten Dingen meine Frau gewesen
ich kann sicher Autofahren aber ich
müsste mich darauf besinnen du bist es
jetzt der fährt also wenn die Ampel rot
ist dass ich dann weiß jetzt muss ich
Bremsen während ich jetzt im Auto sitze
und weiß ein anderer es klingt so als
müssen sie noch mal fünf Stunden in der
Fahrschule machen bevor es losgeht ja
ich werde mit meiner Frau ein bisschen
trainieren
um um das Konzentrieren wir jeder Fahrer
sich oder jede Fahrerin sich
konzentrieren muss ich habe gerade
meinem Fahrer gesagt auf der Fahrt
hierher mit X Radfahren die Kreuzung
quer auf der Straße fahren Autos die
Vorteil sich verschaffen wollen habe ich
gesagt Mensch in Berlin Auto zu fahren
ist wirklich eine höhere kurz also
bleiben sie in Ingolstadt hätte ich da
nur uns allen Wünschen bleiben sie wenn
sie am Steuer sind in Ingolstadt werden
sie Wahlkampfauftritte machen zum
Beispiel im Wahlkampf der CSU wenn es
wieder um die Landtagswahlen geht halten
sich aus wenn der Markus Söder sagt hast
ich brauche dich kann ich auf dich
zählen wenn der Markus Söder das sagt
das was Angela aufhören dann müssen sie
loslassen so das halbe ich bin da einer
der eine lange Erfahrung hat und ich
weiß alles besser als alle anderen das
ist falsch ich habe auch in diesem
Wahlkampf so gut wie keinen Wahlkampf
geführt weil ich glaube die Leute wollen
doch Gesichter der Zukunft sehen
und nicht der Vergangenheit die die
sagen das ist schön aber jetzt gehst
nach Hause und lebst noch hoffentlich
ein paar nette Jahre die Leute wollen
doch Frauen und Männer jetzt sehen von
denen Sie wissen die sind jetzt für
unsere Zukunft zuständig und nicht da
Horst Seehofer als sie den CSU-Vorsitz
abgegeben haben haben sie finde ich also
viele wichtige Dinge gesagt aber für
mich eines der wichtigsten Zitate eines
der berührendsten gegeben die haben
nämlich den anderen den jüngeren den
neuen im Amt hinterlassen vergesst mir
die kleinen Leute nicht was ist ihr Satz
heute am Tag eins nach der Ära als
Innenminister
nach der verlorenen Wahl
gibt es keinen besseren Satz als den zu
wiederholen vergesst mir die kleinen
Leute nicht wenn wir 1,4 Millionen
Stimmen an die SPD verlieren wie ich
glaube aus sozialpolitischen Gründen
Rente Miete Familie
dann haben wir dieses Feld unzureichend
bearbeitet und auch keine Gesichter mehr
wenn sie mal an die Zeit vom blühen und
Geißler ich will jetzt die Vergangenheit
nicht verklären aber wir brauchen wieder
Typen
Leute die um eine richtige Idee kämpfen
die nicht gleich wieder einknicken wenn
mal die höhere Partei Ebene sagt sei mal
ruhig und das fehlt uns zum Beispiel in
der Sozialpolitik und das hat uns auch
im Wahlkampf gefehlt
vielen Dank Horst Seehofer ein
Schlusswort aber noch nicht ganz ich
würde Ihnen gern diese beiden Tassen
schenken die wird wieder schwarz und
eine rote also in Erinnerung an die
große großartige große Koalition und
natürlich auch mit dem Gedanken dass in
der Zeit die jetzt kommt niemand mehr
auf die Idee kommen soll jemals zu sagen
wir Seehofer hat nicht alle Tassen im
Schrank schön dass Sie da waren ich
danke auch wie immer kann man ihren
Schlussworten nichts Besseres hinzufügen